and after days and days and days of
resting studying prepping joe biden
finally trotted out to the podium for
just the second solo press conference
ever as president and as expected it did
not go well at all in fact it was the
longest frankly most painful even
embarrassing presser i've ever witnessed
no doubt he still has lucid moments here
and there but more often than not joe is
clearly lost he is confused especially
off prompter frankly no in the world is
watching this
to be honest i felt
humiliation for the country i really did
you know and that's just the delivery
the substance
was an unmitigated disaster uh that
could have ramifications all around the
globe and what was a blatant attempt to
look strong and confident joe biden
looked deeply unwell now tonight coming
up we're going to fact check his many
lies we'll call out his election
conspiracy theories we'll actually
answer one of his dumb rhetorical
questions and we'll tell you how his
pathetic rhetoric surrounding russia and
nato could have potentially explosive
and very deadly consequences around the
entire globe peter ducey who just faced
off against biden will join us again the
great one mark levin will get his take
and greg gutfeld moments away we'll show
you president trump's initial reaction
as well but we begin with perhaps the
biggest lie of the day and that is
despite major crises on multiple fronts
and an all-time low approval rating at
33 percent joe biden just proudly
announced that his administration has
exceeded all expectations
oh okay sure
inflation is up
uh your signature domestic legislation
is stalled in congress in a few hours
from now the senate uh an effort in the
senate to deal with voting rights and
voting
voting reform legislation is going to
fail
kova 19 is still taking the lives of 1
500 americans every day
and the nation's divisions are just as
raw as they were a year ago did you over
promise to the american public what you
could achieve in your first year in
office and how do you plan to course
correct going forward why are you such
an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
can you think of any other president's
done as much in one year
name one for me
i'm asking you
i'm serious
all right since you asked joe let's take
a look at donald trump's first year in
office shall we in 2017 president trump
he signed 117 bills into law that
included dozens of major legislative
achievements he repealed the individual
mandate in obamacare he signed what was
the biggest tax cut in american history
he eliminated more regulations than the
last what five eight presidents combined
he opened up oil exploration in anwar
and alaska he oversaw massive economic
growth he nominated neil gorsuch to the
supreme court he set a record for first
year judicial appointments to federal
appellate courts he oversaw a historic
reduction in illegal immigration he
bombed the living adam schiff out of
isis and destroyed the caliphate he also
forced nato members to up their
contributions to the military alliance
so what did joe do over the past year
okay joe
true you spent so much money on handouts
that inflation is now at a record
40-year high while the worker shortage
remains dire in the country the average
american family because of your policies
is now spending five thousand dollars
more this year because of your inflation
tax biden shut down the keystone xl
pipeline but he did green light putin's
pipeline uh the nordstrom 2 pipeline to
europe he blocked oil exploration on
federal lands he ended trump's energy
independence policies a year ago this
country was a net exporter of energy and
energy independent and now he's begging
and pleading with opec and russia to
produce more energy that too is a
national embarrassment and worst of all
for you the american consumer all of us
are paying well about a buck fifty more
gallon for gasoline we're going to pay
close to a thousand dollars more on
average heating our homes this year and
we now pay more for every single product
we buy at every store that we go to and
there's no end in sight as now the price
of a barrel of oil worldwide is now
headed to a hundred bucks a barrel and
maybe higher that's a huge reason for
the 40-year high in inflation and joe
obviously has zero understanding of
economics 101 because he never tied
those two things together instead he's
lashing out blaming businesses and
industries and and saying his policies
did not cause this and remember he also
ended trump's border policies he stopped
construction of the border wall he also
ended the state of mexico policy that
was
working it caused record levels of
illegal immigration we had not seen in
what 20 25 years now we can never forget
the 13 americans who were killed because
of biden's botched withdrawal from
afghanistan or the thousands of
americans and and green card holders and
allies that he abandoned when he said he
wouldn't do it remember he also promised
to shut down the virus that never
happened either joe was lying the entire
time we not not only did he not shut it
down we had more people that died from
covert 19 in 2021 than 2020. uh he said
i didn't see omicron coming and in the
meantime when we needed most he ran out
of covert tests he ran out of monoclonal
antibodies he's done nothing to mass
produce the antivirals that for the
first time today even mentioned we have
now more americans dead under his watch
than donald trump but according to the
white house biden did build a lot of new
windmills and electric charging stations
okay that's really helping us all out a
lot but as for the unity that joe
promised in his of inauguration speech
well today joe couldn't even be honest
about that take a look
i know that you dispute the
characterization that you called folks
who would oppose those voting bills
as being bull connor or george wallace
but you said that they would be sort of
in the same camp no i didn't say that
look what i said go back and read what i
said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
do i ask every elected official in
america
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history
they present a
choice do you want to be the sign the
side of dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
well he chose to be beside let's see the
former klansman robert byrd and stop
integration of schools because he didn't
want public schools to be racial jungles
it was lie after lie after lie in this
presser today now even joe's old friend
dick durbin thought that that speech was
too divisive joe does not seem to grasp
reality at this point in time he just
lies and lies over and over again here
are a few more examples take a look you
decide why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
well
i'm not
if you notice i haven't attacked anybody
publicly
any senator any any any any congressman
my bill back better plan will address
the biggest cost of working families
face every day and it will do all this
without raising a single penny in taxes
on people making under four hundred
thousand dollars a year
and for the first time in a long time
this country's working people actually
got a raise
we've seen record job creation record
economic growth in the past year
anybody who listened to the speech
i did not say
that they were going to be george
wallace or
bull connor
biden's blatant lies are a culmination
of two deeply concerning issues one he's
always been a kind of slimy dishonest
politician to be blunt two joe is now in
a very steep very obvious cognitive
decline it's becoming harder and harder
for him to keep his tall tales straight
and as a result you the american people
well you don't seem to have much
confidence or believe that joe is
competent to serve today james rosen
asked biden about this cognitive decline
and joe was not interested in giving an
answer totally unaware take a look
i'd like to
i'd like to raise a delicate
subject
but with utmost respect for your life
accomplishments and the high office you
hold
a poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49 percent of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
uh strongly affirmed that statement
well let you all make the judgment
whether they're correct well so the
question i have for you sir if you'd let
me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
no idea whatsoever well we must admit we
were a little ahead of the curve because
we were telling you about this during
the campaign uh and by the way he's
living in an alternate universe remember
how did he not know what let's go
brandon meant and just today at the
presser well in between a few lucid
moments biden he struggled mightily we
got the tape to prove it again we'll let
you decide
we passed a lot of things that people
don't even understand what's all that's
in it understandably
one of the things that i remember saying
and i'll end this i think it's extremely
realistic to say to people
because let me back up
so whether or not we can actually get an
election and by the way i haven't given
up we haven't finished the vote yet on
what's going on on on the uh um on
voting rights and the john lewis bill
and others
um
the uh uh
harris please
very few schools are closing
over 95
are still open
uh
has is becoming
much more informed on
the um
the motives of
um
some of the political
players
and some of the uh
and the political parties
one one more question uh mr president um
by the way it's a quarter of guys now so
i'm going to do this just let's if you
answer me easy questions i'll give you a
quick answer
there's a reason i stopped joking about
it a long time ago because it's not
funny
our enemies are watching this it's scary
it's troubling we the american people
can see what's going on you're
witnessing an obvious cognitive decline
but the saddest part of all this are so
are america's enemies you know vladimir
putin president xi the muellers in iran
in fact putin is now amassing troops at
the border of ukraine ready to attack
cause a massive war in europe putin
likely thinks biden is too weak to
respond and today biden essentially well
not only confirmed but fast-tracked
putin's plan to invade ukraine so long
as it's it's it's well is it going to be
a minor incursion
wow take a look
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having to
fight about what to do and not do etc
you think putin's going to hold back now
200 000 troops that he's amassed there
ukrainian officials are now at this hour
freaking out rightly so with some
expressing complete shock and grief at
biden's comments u.s intel officials
they're now reportedly deeply concerned
and troubled but by the way they were at
the start of this day our nato allies
frankly are terrified of what they saw
today and what might happen next because
of what biden said at this press
conference now clearly war by putin is
imminent and he kind of got a the green
light from joe biden that there's not
going to be any real significant
consequences we're going to put
sanctions on them oh okay that's going
to work uh you don't know how to put
sanctions on them because if you did
you'd have to out produce them as far as
energy goes and that would mean you'd be
supplying our western european allies
with the lifeblood of the world's
economy that we have the ability to
provide that you prevent us from
providing now this is why we cannot have
a president with that's a cognitive mess
in our white house the consequences will
be felt all over the world and today
former president trump had this to say
about joe's disastrous day listen to
this
i imagine you saw most of this press
conference and no i did
and joe biden said he's had enormous
progress during his presidency i don't
see it that way do you
well progress in destroying our country
yes i think that's been tremendous hey
i'd like him to do well you want to know
the truth forget about politics i'd love
him to do well i'd love him to be
representing our country i think it's
the lowest our country's ever been
you look at the border with millions of
people coming in you look at inflation
you look at no more energy independence
no it's uh we have a much different
country than we had a year ago
now we have an announcement about
president trump later in the show we'll
have more of this interview the great
one mark levin will also join us but
first i want to take a moment and answer
a question that joe biden asked at
today's press conference here's the
question he asked well numerous times
take a listen
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for
well for the record i'm a registered
conservative but i vote republican
because that's pretty much the only
party that's even near conservative now
just one joe because my list is
expansive let's start with energy
independence that you took away from
this country let's start with the
keystone xl pipeline let's get it back
online drilling on federal lands
lowering taxes ending burdensome
regulation open schools school choice
parents in control of their kids
education law and order safety security
so every american can pursue happiness
free and fair trade deals peace through
strength free market solutions to health
care yes that also protect pre-existing
conditions we believe in liberty and
freedom and capitalism in our
constitution and the u.s bill of rights
upheld by constitutionalists on the
bench but joe isn't particularly
familiar with any of those beliefs
because joe doesn't actually talk to any
republicans or conservatives and he
doesn't reach across the aisle
republicans were pushed out of any
negotiation with bill back better or
bilbao broke as i call it uh they were
not at all
involved in in this power grab that
they're trying even at this hour tonight
which we'll talk about in a minute
instead he's hiding away at the white
house and spending 25 percent of his
time at the beach somewhere in delaware
all while his socialist handlers are
fundamentally trying to transform this
country into a new green deal socialist
utopia with the slimmest of majorities
in the house and the senate so i guess
congratulations joey you might be the
worst president in modern american
history but don't worry joey you know
you'll be the last to know it because it
appears your steep cognitive decline is
only getting worse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else